they share these shelters side by side  with their livestock  humans and animals barely able to stand  firani bibi is 96 years old she was  carried here the house collapsed on her  legs she's been sitting on this wooden  bed in the sun for three weeks relying  on handouts from locals  all they have is their goat and her  rusty walking frame  she looked deeply in my eyes and told me  her husband stayed back with the older  children she doesn't know if they are  dead or alive  she's telling me that there's a hole in  there  the few items she has shown me they have  no shoes her feet are bleeding injuries  from her escape her children are riddled  with mosquito bites their eyes infected  some days they eat  some days they don't  when the children cry it breaks my heart  and i cry too she tells me  but they never complain  sky news  pakistan